hello everyone welcome to another
episode of red lips orange car I'm Alana
PS I'm joined by mati sleemoth everybody
and also joven Shia huh I'm here what do
people know you from uh uh you can find
me on the internet from Smosh games I
also got my own stuff with the YouTube
channel the joke and Shire and yeah just
kind of run the internet Jeff and I come
from that's makes you a first name you
lost name yeah it's it's nothing too
exciting it's cool whose name was Ryan
Eisen tragus oi I always called him
Verizon trigger big fan pretty cool yeah
mine just came from when I was working
at this company that had it was just
your first name at the company's name
for your email and so I send out this
important memo and I was walking by
someone and there my email wasn't Joshua
at the company it was J open Shire I was
walking by someone's like who names
their kid okay I'm sorry I'm the new guy
my name is it's Josh he's like no you're
shy which is also Accounts Payable
accidently very often loot me and do
accounting emails and I'd be like oh I
know too much a pain in the ass like
what every month I have to do invoices
for my freelancers and you're the person
I clearly emailed the most every single
time will be like everyone's like sorry
it's like disregard what you saw we have
to Shannon's at what can i always
accidentally tag the wrong one and it's
funny because one of them is like a head
of very different at least that's all
like internal I'm very blind and I'll
just like type in my emails as I need to
and then sometimes we'll just like hit
some random contact that I once knew a
long time ago and
no clue who they are now like Brian at
cellulite Network I send emails like my
agent and someone else and that someone
else was not the person that I was
supposed to send it to and they're like
yeah this is you man all right let's get
to the show look at money is historic
but today mine is from New Orleans
Louisiana and it is titled we met at the
hi-ho longe man seeking woman you were
visiting
I'm sorry loser dead dwarf it's really
looking to find you again all these
[ __ ] birds around you man seeking
woman
you're visiting from Texas with your
friend we chatted at the bar had to hila
shots and played connect for outside in
the courtyard your friend's phone died
and she had to lead to charge it so we
wanted around the French for a while
wander on the Frenchman for a while
found another bar to relax in and you
suggested that we go to the chyme tree
in City Park oh so we called up an uber
and went we sat under the tree for a
little bit until some security guard
forced us to leave we walked around the
park until we found a new spot the city
later you called up another uber and
went back to your Airbnb we were so
drunk that we didn't exchange contact
info but I loved the night we had all I
got was her first name Stephanie I'd
love for us to hang out again if you
ever come back to town that's really
sweet
I think it's really sweet too because I
also like none of this is like no no
this is gross
and to me it's like these two clearly
not crossly I'm actually I didn't know
that stuff like this existed on yeah I'd
like everything I looked up and we'll
find out in a second it's just weird
yeah everything's weird lotta ticks
yeah you do have to like search for the
nice stuff but I have one that I'm like
saving for the right person that's very
very nice but this one is lovely and
it's also like okay so they met at a bar
- hi homeland the high her lounge of
course where the dwarfs are so he was
clearly from New Orleans this girl and
her friend was from Texas and then they
hit it off the friend had to go and so I
don't know I'd like I've had moments
like this in San Cisco
we're like I've met someone who's
visiting from out of town and then show
them around the city for a night or a
couple days like we've just hit it off
and like totally in a platonic way yeah
and it's like one adventure exactly and
so they had this thing I like the idea
that they played you know what I'm
assuming is like giant Kinect for
outside in this bar which a great day
this is
MW right and for them yeah do you think
that he was doing it like in the
interests of finding her platonically
because I'm of the impression that he
wants to find out and get her number so
that he can yeah it's a great it sounds
like they hit it off I mean it seems
like it started as platonic but he's
like hey I had an amazing night what if
we had another one like this yeah
totally
I'm so excited for this show for the
time when you guys actually like the
person listens to the show to find the
missing gonna be great well I'm worried
that people gonna lie to us people gonna
be like oh yeah I totally met up with
this person that was totally my story
and I'm just gonna be stoked about it
yeah I don't I just think it's cute that
they went to this park and we got yellow
bar security guard because I've
drunkenly went to a park with someone at
night that I was a Soviet got yelled at
by a security guard and then went
somewhere else in the park like I find
that really sweet too yeah I think about
the times that I've been drunk and it
was like it was like definitely yeah I'm
trying to think if I have a story like
that damn story like that well you met
someone that you like never contacted oh
that you didn't oh my well kind of
before I like started really doing
YouTube stuff I did a extra work for
movies and I was on the set of I was on
the set of the social network and it was
like so there's the scene where brenda
song meets meets the main guy and
they're in the hall biggest Bill Gates
is talking so I'm in like the front row
camera left screen right and I'm sitting
next to this cute girl and because it
was just like an eight-hour day of stand
next to each other like we just weaved
like we were joking back and forth had a
wonderful time and then she invited me
to like she was hanging out with friends
that night but I had like another
project to get to because I was then
starting to get him to YouTube stuff and
so I didn't go and I never got a contact
information there anything that one
event could have changed my entire ya
know one of my best friend's angel for
the works was a same time for five years
he was a full time extra in New York
he's met his girlfriend at the time
on the set of Gilmore Girls and they
were just like I don't know that you
were next to each other all [ __ ] day
and they yeah it's it's great you'll see
him in tons of episodes of 30 rock and
it's like kind of ruin that show for me
a little bit and then I'll watch it and
be like Oh Andrew that was the closest
I've ever had to threesome with my
friend Andrew was when I was like with
my girlfriend of time and we were just
in the background you can't my was like
sex ruin a story but it was yeah it was
like I was like put on background noise
because there are other people in the
house and we put on South Park and the
humancentipad episode of South Park came
on which is literally people [ __ ] in
each other's mouths and that's the sound
effect really you know what do this now
let's play Mario Kart I guess like all
of a sudden person's like no let's do
this you discovered I had just YouTube
like music playing in the background but
then turned into like recommended videos
and there's just my voice in the
background that's not good and I'm like
I'm into this
I'm still trying to like figure out at
this I feel like everyone that I have
met like in the past seven years
literally since I got into games was so
easy for me to track down that like you
know the same applies to YouTube space
it's like you meet all the same people
who have a network it's really easy to
find it's easy to find someone who has
who a clearly probably knows people you
know and B has won over five ten hundred
thousand followers right and like
someone who'd be like I met this guy
last night he like this you work at this
company around opossum yeah totally and
it's like I also I empathize with the
fact that he's like we were both really
drunken we did not exchange contact good
fun yeah you know what the last time it
happened was when my mom was actually
visiting me she came for a vacation and
my mom just like loves getting quite
wine drunk so we got wine drunk at a bar
Venice Beach yeah it doesn't especially
for like 50 year old white women it's
like dude one drink and we met a bunch
of guys at Venice Beach who like mom is
just crazy so she's like convinced him
to buy us drinks and it worked out great
and it was like super cool night I
really wanna show cuz she's so great
she's probably and I did actually end up
getting the guy's number but it was I
completely plutonic that we just hung
out with them until it was like sunrise
guy ended up walking on star citizen so
accidentally he had a girlfriend and
told me about it man it was like a very
nice completely platonic drunken night
where nothing about it felt sexual or
uncomfortable at all but it's just like
yeah I met this [ __ ] dude at a bar
and no friends it was it was very cool I
don't have his number any more than so
shout out to star citizen guy maybe I
should posted on this case oh so we need
to give this person a name hi ho Henry I
think because he already said the girl's
name is Stephanie my name is Stephanie
alright I was gonna say doc yours is way
better just like it's got the
alliteration yeah yeah isn't it almost
nicer if they never get in contact ever
again yeah that's like I've had a
[ __ ] great night and then it's just
done I am a happily married man love my
wife but now
have this magical like story of this
random person I met on set it's just
what I got my life could have been
different just like that was the thing
that happen it's like it's like we
before sunrise if before sunset had
never been made for it's like oh this
this couple had an amazing night
together and then they just went their
separate ways so he's gonna be like oh
that should be about that there is a
years later they made it where they met
a gun and then 10 years later and if you
believe in soulmates and then the
continuation of energy and whatnot is it
probably just these two people
intertwining throughout life in time
just one night at a time that is a movie
I want to see I just got ok we'll do it
again no my boyfriend and I had been in
the same room I think we calculated
seven times had an interaction once and
he had seen me DJ live once before we
actually met seven times over like the
span of like three years before we'd
actually like know formally met each
other know when you had the meeting that
eventually led to you guys dating was
were you guys aware of those events
beforehand no we only figured it out
that's great yes I had no idea and it
was like the the one where we actually
technically spoke to each other was at
e3 he was with Bonnie and Ashley from
rusa teeth and I walked over and I was
like hey and I was drunk as [ __ ] and he
was sitting next to them like planning
that show for the next day and as I was
walking away he was like who was that
and I think actually was like it's a
long she was very drunk but we like
technically like I would have I think I
probably walked out because like I feel
like I know what I'm gonna say to him
it's something like really smooth
and I was terrible about licensure
technically we will like in us the same
conversation and then I walked away and
I didn't remember that that was him
until we were like wait a minute
that was you that was citizens larger
speech I love events like that and it
reminds me it's not me if I'm rambling
too much that happens a lot but there
was a there was a street fighter for
event right before that the launch out
here in Los Angeles that I have since
had conversations with people that are
like oh like years later are now like
major names in the in the in the field
just like industry geek skate space area
that everyone was starting out and we
were all at that one launch party yeah
yeah I was like so many random people
like someone I knew that runs like
comicbook.com now was there Matthew
Mercer was there because he was the
voice of fei-long
this up-and-coming voice actor at the
time he's so great it's just like
everyone that I know now that was just
starting out in the industry was
athletes this was learning access to
that yes and it just like that's where
everyone brands from yeah yeah it's
really cool yeah and it's like even
thinking that we've the amount of people
that you probably will meet at some
point here in the same room as you would
any three press conference or something
that's a shot it's just like it's it's
crazy story number two well that's me
well mine you can do brain the podcaster
you can't see when I scroll through like
why is that yeah you just pick and
choose what you think mine is called I
grabbed your boobs on Sunset so romantic
Saturday night I was out with my buddies
walking around on sunset going from bar
to bar club to club etc you were
presumably with your girlfriends as we
headed near each other we did not make
any eye contact it is as though we were
trying not to look at each other however
I was secretly trying to so he's
painting a picture here okay he's like
what well we were trying not to look at
it you know
looking at my nails after this first
paragraph and after hearing the title
what do you think happens next I think
he grabbed the [ __ ] noise okay that's
what having some sort of fog horn unless
the titles yeah because of this I wasn't
looking where I was going I tripped on a
crack in the pavement and fell forward
right as you were passing by my arms
flailed about and I tried to grab the
nearest sturdy thing to steady myself
that nearest thing ended up being your
rack oh my god word for word verbatim
him was this an accident was it an
offence it as an accident yes but was it
was it an accident was it real this is
not no you guys on the show he does
entertain the idea that there definitely
really yes
her boobs though were they are worth a I
guess we'll find out when we get to that
unfortunately your breasts words dirty
or sturdy enough so I kept falling
probably real along the way your shirt
and bra were torn off in the process
your knockers exposed to the night air
ballon solid bounce with delight and
glee
that's all right okay it's getting weird
okay right although possible you could
have someone like trip and fall and like
accidentally that's enough you can
absolutely and you get like pole like a
you could pull a nipple out accidentally
you sneeze like when you like if two
people are drowning and one person just
play the other person's rounds because
things about going to the beach in a
bikini is that you shits gonna come out
constantly anytime that you like all
right I just gotta readjust this
permanently so almost immediately you
came down upon me your fists rain down
Hellfire the likes of which I've never
experienced repeatedly apparently friend
quickly joined in pummeling me with my
own friends stood there watching
giggling giggling gaily as if their
kindergarten classmate
just food their pants during recess and
use the word food it was when you were
pepper spraying the [ __ ] out of me when
we locked eyes for a moment it was
incredibly painful to keep my eyes open
due to the intense sting from the pepper
spray but I noticed how goddamn gorgeous
your blue eyes were I think I noticed a
moment of hesitation almost admiration
perhaps a hint of a smile formed on your
face and for a second I thought you were
going to kiss me but then you
head-butted me directly into the
sidewalk rendering me unconscious
alright this however did not stop you
from kicking me in the side spitting on
my face and stealing my wallet all the
while my friends continued laughing and
whooping it up like a bunch of drunken
rednecks at a hoedown I had hoped to
find your phone numbers scratched into
my chest with many other scratches from
your fingernails but alas when I came to
nothing just blood and a few scattered
teeth I sincerely hope you read this
message because I think we had a
connection I would like to see you wear
this I would like to see where this
might lead as long as it's not the I see
you again okay
theory that this is one that I think it
started off as the truth like maybe that
happened and II brushed up boob but he
decided to make it super entertaining
and to make her think to exaggerate the
[ __ ] out of it so he's like the way that
I'm gonna get attention it's not gonna
be like hey accidently brushy boob I'm
really sorry is he's gonna make it like
this huge [ __ ] spectacle so she's
like okay this is funny no this guy he
works in Houston a social media I know
this because he understands viral market
you're absolutely right you went with
like here's what happened here's the
here's the situation now we're gonna get
this shared all over the place which
it's working
I think I think I've seen a couple of
them go like that and that one's like
the the theory that she's more likely to
see it if it's shed everywhere well he
did he say where they want it's on
Sunset which is to say like when it's
the email this to myself I'd so it
doesn't say exactly when but if you're
even remotely close to this situation I
think you remember I think he yeah I
think what happened is probably that
they did walk past each other she didn't
[ __ ] notice him at all anything in
his head that they were like totally not
true no that he accidentally like maybe
tripped and actually like brushed up
boob and he's like I'm gonna make this
[ __ ] big so she finds out and thinks
I'm funny it's well written it's it's I
see I'm a sucker for plans and I see you
again that is really good I do think
though to kind of counter your your
non-believing of the try not to stare at
each other as a socially awkward
individual I'm walking down the street I
will find every other reason not to be
looking forward to the point where it's
almost obvious that I'm trying not to
make eye contact because it's just the
weird all mean the same yeah right so
he's trying not to look but secretly
wants to he's doing that corner of his
eye thing and she's like pretending to
talk to her friends you know I get that
too yeah you're right that like totally
happens as well sorry then he just he's
just sees it as like oh she's just
trying not to look she's injured but
maybe she's just really [ __ ] awkward
yeah I totally get there I was like I if
it was truly an accidental trip and then
brush of the boob well that wasn't a
brush of the boob that was like a full
everyone's done an accidental touch of
the boob I'm yeah but he's not guilty
cast the first stone I'm touching I'm a
I'm a cartoon character not on purpose
they just my life just turns into it and
even my physical activities like I have
like when I I just every every small
slight raised in a pavement I will trip
over in my arms do wave all over the
place and so I see like a lot of food
like if I could just see the oh god yeah
hi I've definitely had a stranger
accidentally touched me on the boob
before but I feel like I've also like
actually touched people's jungle
I think so well at a club I've
definitely had people just be like Alan
touchy Boop and that's happened it's
very common it's so weird to me that you
don't get kicked out for it people will
just be like I'm going to touch your
vagina gonna be like hey security and
they're like [ __ ] crazy regardless
I've definitely accidentally touched
people people's junk before that one's
not a fun one it's like I think the last
time it happened to me was on a plain
chunk yeah like if you brush yeah it's
like you bombuh I've accidentally
brushed into junk it happened I was
walking with that punch because I love
that so much classic book yeah I think
this has happened to most people and I
also think for the girl that it's kind
of okay if someone actually only touches
you I would like it they made a joke
about it I would be like I would
probably like that like if someone was
like oh my god I'm so sorry like please
don't beat the [ __ ] out of me then I
would be like probably find that kind of
endearing mm like I think that's like a
smooth way to handle it just like make a
fun joke out of that she's like you're
gonna kick my ass right now I'm really
sorry just give me your number and we'll
forget about all this I think that's
very you just nailed it we need to give
you a story a name see grabbing that
grab usin just seems like low-hanging
fruit I like it sometimes low-hanging
fruit isn't bad hi do you know if you're
hungry it's there okay my story the
headline is got me out of jail this is
Austin misconnections
landfill woman got me out of jail last
week so gorgeous and I think I made you
nervous with my eyes and eyes has like
the little what do they called the
squiggly lines next to it tilde tilde
thank you
we talked about school and you gave me a
pep talk about going back and getting my
feet wet again I told you I was looking
at a nursing Haleh if you remember me I
might be younger but I want to give you
a night on the town that you will never
forget XX age 20 there's a couple things
unpack here yes first question can
someone you don't know get you out of
jail
yes why though how does that work how
it's just you you have you have a bail
someone can pay and get you out why
would someone do that like a stranger
pay it right so well maybe they know
that did you wait maybe I don't know why
would that I don't think there's any
like like bail fairies that just go
around to different jails like hmm I'm
gonna let out this person here's mm it's
it seems like they hadn't met before
then because she says what was he in
jail or don't know
see there's we need the prequel story I
mean if he has a promising nursing
career ahead you just said I told you I
was looking into nothing so yeah he's
considering nursing maybe he's really
good with the read the beginning again
got me out of jail last week yeah so
gorgeous and I think I made you nervous
with my eyes we talked about school and
you gave me a pep talk about going back
and getting my feet wet again okay I
don't think this is a bail thing I think
he got into an altercation or a sticky
situation and maybe she helped she was
the one if the wheels were in motion she
wasn't there he would have done some
dumb [ __ ] he would have put him in jail
I could see that he would write that
incorrectly because some of this is like
some bad punctuation [ __ ] in here so I
guess
[Music]
well you didn't know anything at 20
you've learned everything in the last
four years
sure yeah yeah I got out of jail plenty
of time tonight explain maybe the long
way behind a fact that he's 20 maybe
this was a drinking thing and maybe my
assumption go to jail for drinking which
you don't go to jail if you underage
drink okay so it could be he got into
some kind of altercation and she helped
him or she was like the officer that
will bitterly got him out of jail
because the pep-talk thing it's like
she's like a woman who's like hey like
yeah I like that okay she was the
officer yeah that like talked him off
the ledge oh yes like changed his life
direction like don't go down this path
because you're gonna what you're gonna
end up in here all the time you don't
want this life go back to school and so
because she's being vaguely nice and
helpful
he's like she this is like a loan
officer he falls in between his raps the
one edited this out of the song with
Nicki Minaj and Drake only he has a line
that says I piss greatness like goldish
yellow and I hate it so much that I
literally edited his voice out of that
song it's greatness like gold is right
yeah he is bad you're dehydrated oh
don't do that
anyway so but can we really look at that
lines I still don't understand it I why
I I pissed greatness like it's gold as
yellow well what's the is gold is yellow
oh that's bad so then right aren't no
gold is good though gold is good oh is
it because he's just like old equals
money maybe yeah Goldy because Riggs
his greatness like goldish yellow no so
everything I touch is gold oh he's not
like the hand of Midas but a little
yellow is also like it's not real gold
that's like fake gold yeah that's just
that's just yellow at a certain point
what's fake gold is yellow it's like
big old debate goal you know classic son
[ __ ] fake gold girl so I yeah I
subscribe to the theory that this is a
cop so I think the the Sun gorgeous and
I think I made you nervous with my eyes
line is the is my favorite part of this
because it's like no she's nervous
because you were [ __ ] in jail and
she's trying to get you she's like
alright well I don't know why area fall
but get your [ __ ] together you're making
me uncomfortable because you're
obviously aggressively attracted to me
it's like this is all very weird for
everyone with my eyes it's like I feel
like you would and I might be younger
but I want to give you a night on the
town that you will never forget so this
is like to me that just sounds like I
just kind of like [ __ ] you also yeah
person I love you 20 you you can't give
me a night on the town because I want to
go to a bar about the door guy being
like you were underage you're absolutely
right
yeah the night on the town is like we go
to a park we get you buy me the alcohol
I don't buy it myself and then we drink
yeah like we discussed before in the
children's playground mmm I like to
think that your person
Lil Wayne in this game eventually
becomes hyah ho Henry hmm yeah and then
so so he goes on that that night of the
town winds up being this night this is
in Austin meaning and Stephanie was from
Texas mm-hmm Stephanie's the car then
after Stephanie's after he doesn't ever
find her again
he then winds up having to go out on a
night on the town with his friends and
they were super drunk in LA it's like we
just got to meet new people we just got
to go somewhere new they travel across
they they go to California's writing
skills have significantly improved this
whole time because it's studying nothing
yeah holy [ __ ] your writing skills don't
prove because you're studying you're
studious yeah maybe two words I agree
it's hard I don't think it makes me a
better writer it probably would you
going to university probably makes you a
better writer like right now you better
social skills yeah yeah and then your
social skills will again eventually turn
into better community that being said I
think this nursing student would laugh
that would make the pooed my pants just
mmm
I'm studying nursing and yes Facebook
page that is called procrastinating
which is just the joke about how when
you are procrastinating and you
masturbate like jokes about that that's
good let's go to Travis Betty get some
some brand deals on it yes like I like
the idea that you think that people who
study know what executive means you wear
a suit now you still I think I know who
described her jobs is we write book
reports about toys to all the younger
listeners out there just know that the
adults that you think we know what we're
doing in our lives no we're just kids
we're just kids making fun of things
absolutely sure yeah back to the
cinematic universe of nice boy who goes
up and I like this a lot
thank you started as little Wayne
graduated and I'm like oh Henry little I
like calling him little because he's
short do you think he know that's the
lil also know he wouldn't kill you those
tears don't represent the people he's
killed
Romeo yeah oh it was a little bow-wow
yeah because he got bit on the but mine
was grabbing that grabs it you're right
yeah Roberson we decided he became Irish
yeah
don't know why you're gonna take a few
drinks walking down the street couldn't
start it off as yeah because of that
faithful name okay so did the end part
we're separating them as being they're
not the same person anymore who is the
most likely to succeed at finding it's
not finding them is connection uh based
on by
Marketing I think mine yo is this going
to be shared to me yes yeah but the one
you didn't say like what day it was and
so it's like hard to like pinpoint the
person and it has potential for them all
to have been super [ __ ] drunk so she
might not even remember a strong
argument for hi ho yeah is that super
sense it seems like a like a romantic
night that both people yes actually
genuinely this no longer this is one's
where's like a Lana's like yours if this
person's a cop I think mine where's this
one like if this night was as sort of
fun and carefree and unexpected and
romantic as he said and they were both
super [ __ ] up and didn't exchange
numbers I could see her the next day
being like [ __ ] I really like that guy
when did it did say how long ago it was
but like he didn't say like several
months ago because you know how some of
them like five years ago I couldn't find
super recently I think yours is the most
likely next on how specific it is and
probably the only problem is I mean
granted he's let me shadow yeah yours
was shared more but given that it's on
Sunset it's possible none of these
people live in LA that's true oh so true
uh where's this one we know he lives in
New Orleans but she lives in Texas and
and did not mind down even further say
it does go viral let's say she finds it
she likes it that was a [ __ ] I hated
that moment grabbed my tit you monster
that's not gonna be the story we tell
our children could go either way
she could also be in a relationship we
don't know or it's literal and that's
the whole thing happened she committed a
crime frankly she's mad at him feel like
publicizing him that puts her
reputations all over her time all of her
friends committed a crime and
technically his friends are complacent
yeah I know you meant what uh what's
that Seinfeld to jail and the season
finale what are you laughing at a dude
yeah yeah
and that's why show ends at the four of
them going to jail because they watch a
fat dude who's the Good Samaritan the
Good Samaritan Law oh my god that's
insane but it's a good way to wrap up
the show because the other thing is
you're going to jail because you're
terrible people because this whole show
is about how the four of you checks out
people and isn't it end on a joke that
they tell in the first episode but
buttons yeah yeah yeah that's cool I
know I'm definitely friends over
Seinfeld but that was pretty brilliant I
am too yeah so okay we put I think
heigh-ho Henry is number one yup hands
down grabbing my crabbit grab him a
crabber son cuz you have to see it
accent this is number two and then a
little low easy yeah yeah you're right
behind someone yeah Austin yeah they're
still good Drake Drake is there also
yeah Young Money do I really like that
bed rock song good song yeah it's a it's
a Flintstones reference nice nice very
nice why is that well why not we've done
it several times soon can we do a hole I
do you do is just surprising we go today
obviously that's ironic
shameless plug in the game
there's a there's a skin for Loki
[Music]
that's really walk in return the Jedi
and he plays will oh wow he's probably
the second most dirty [ __ ]
that's right like this is a good but
very weird place to wrath Monty why can
people find you you can find me on all
social media at Nick biggity MCB IgG itg
why how about you Joshua what's up guys
I'm the joven share just
Instagram Twitter YouTube the joven
Shire that's that's the stick you'll
find me I do all things
geek lifestyle news movie stuff video
games just about youtube.com slash the
joven child also yep cool and I match
our Alana so just my name in the middle
of chars odd and I forgot first
yesterday put your name the little up
the middle it was jiggly Alana puffs
like a lot of puffs not a fan of that
one see the fan art for that one yep no
no